As we go to our next game,
Cringeworthy: Hollywood Edition.
Our lovely and honorable
#PointsMe winner Richard
is new here to Hollywood,
but, uh... as you might be able
to tell from the fact
that he's not currently made
of green juice.
But he will soon learn
that Hollywood
is an awkward place,
which is why our speed game
tonight is
Cringeworthy: Hollywood Edition,
inspired a long time ago by
a redditor named boxofkangaroos.
Using only three words, please
say something Hollywood-related
that will make us cringe
in 60 seconds. And begin.
-April.
-New Kardashian discovered.
Points. Kyle.
Scientology open house.
Points. Rich.
Homeless guy's screenplay.
Points. April.
Charlie Sheen's here!
Points. Rich.
Craigslist casting couch.
Points. Kyle.
Vine star's opinions.
Vegan blow jobs.
I don't think
those are certified vegan.
No meat.
Apes.
Tom Cruise's Grindr.
Points. Kyle.
Dane Cook's music.
-Points.
-Is that a real thing?
-Ugh.
-Yes, Richard.
Paul Blart 3.
Yes, points.
Points for that.